Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters here to answer some very important questions
Here's the question we get can I just buy a program right from you and how do you program it? What do you know what to do?
How has that done? How does that work? The answer is quite simple. It's yes, that's what we do
I've been doing this for many many years started working with right machines back in the 90s
So whatever year it is now you could do the math. So currently we are programming the true rife f122
That's the latest model of true rife that is the
model that we used I think it's the best for multiple reasons. I have a bunch of videos on that
To be a rife is only as good as the you know several factors
It has to have enough power to penetrate your body
If it has more power than that, that's great, but it's kind of wasted if the bulb is next to you
You want to have a bulb you have to use light frequency first of all
So any of these little handheld machines that you're holding different things and stuff to be they might have validity
But in my mind, I'm just giving you my opinion
I don't think it really is going to make a big difference in your health
So it has to use light frequency light as a photon carry it out of wavelength and it's using the frequencies going through that
Light wave length. So everything is programmed on a laptop
So we actually provide a laptop with our
Purchases if you purchase a rife from us the program will be the current version six at this time of this
Making this video if they ever come up with a new version you'll get the latest version
And you get all that comes with it about 25 almost 2,500 other programs for just about everything you could possibly think of
Possibly my specific programming for you. So all the programming is on the laptop the machine
Then connects to the laptop and when you hit run on the program on the laptop
It sends the program to the machine you can close the laptop
That's what we recommend people do and put the bulb next to you
That's how you use the machine. So many times people will put
This little machine that you see in blue the true rFF 122 put that underneath the bed put the laptop at their bed side
And put the bulb in bed with it. Why are we talking in bed because we typically tell members?
To use it at night while they sleep now
You can run any of the other programs that are available some of them are three minutes long
Some of them are three hours long depending on the program
You can run those any time during the day
But when I write a program I'm typically writing programs for overnight use unless you specify that you want shorter programs
Some people do please write two hour programs for cancer. Please write you know three hour programs for my autoimmune disease
However, you want the program right now gladly accommodate that and do that but with
Patients that are members that have cancer we have always written overnight programs because I want them to get you know the right
Frequency's while they sleep so they can live during the day. That's just part of our philosophy
I don't know what you tied to a machine or anything like that that you have to do during the day and then you know
Sometimes you know you're feeling better. You just don't do it. So at night you have to sleep anyhow
Hey, you might as well be you know using the therapy while you're sleeping. I think there's a huge benefit to that
So that's how we program it now it comes in a case
So the true right machine is in the case it also comes with a foot bath eye on pro wave
That a lot of people use on a daily basis and some people don't use it at all
It just it does take time to do it comes also with the crystal hammer to which is an upgrade
I just think there's benefit to the crystal hammer tube and split the frequencies and help when a frequency when an organism or something is
Trying to morph just try to stay alive. I think the crystal hammer tube is a nice upgrade
And also like I said comes with the laptop computer. It comes with the grounding mat that you use
I recommend only when you're doing the eye and pro wave and then it comes with the computer that's not seen here
So how is it programmed
Okay, that's a question. I always get well to be honest with you
It's really programmed
All the progress that by me and it's based upon I've been doing this a long time. So
I have written programs for you know, just about every health condition that you could think of
And if somebody has one that I have never written a program for that
I'm doing research finding frequencies and writing a program for that specific thing
I just feel like this is my mission to help people and if they come to me with something I don't have never helped
You know anybody with before then I figured out how to use right frequencies for that
Remember, we're not promising to cure. This isn't quote-unquote a treatment. We're not offering medical advice
this is
frequencies to
stimulate your body to do things
against a
Disorder dysfunction and bring back function to your body
That's the goal of rife treatment. So I'm using my experience. I'm using all my data and my experience
Along with what has been done by other practitioners
This is what your home screen will look like on your true right
So when you open up your home screen, it's gonna look just like this. It's hard to read. It's very small
But you see folders on the left hand side where it starts with autism
Sets body function programs cancer programs clear-line programs
So there's programs in those folders and then it goes down down below those little yellow folders
It goes to an alphabetical list of all the programs that you scroll through it. That literally I think there's 2,400
Plus programs now
But we want to get really specific to you. So if you're gonna purchase a pro a rife machine for
From us, we're gonna I'm gonna program it for you. So
In the store if you purchase a rife machine that says prerequisite complete this educational intake form
And you'll click on that and it'll bring you to a form
It's not a medical intake form. It's an educational intake form where you give us
How do you want me to program your rife? So that's where like I said before if you want
Hey, you know, I have a son with you know autism. Could you put some pre like if you can't sit for more than 15 minutes
Can you put 15-minute programs together day programs for him? I have a daughter that has you know headaches
Can you put some programs in for her? It's best to specify minutes if you possibly can or
Hours or whatever and maybe I have breast cancer. So I would like an overnight program for my breast cancer
So tell us all that stuff. So it gives me clues on how to write this program and then I actually as I create that program
I put it as a a your name and it might be if it's a family program
There's a program for your husband and then the wife and then the and then the children in that folder
It will be a folder and it'll have the names of those people. So it's best to specify that as best you can on that form
Who you want those four and the minutes and
Because it just gives me instructions at how to do it best for you because again, you know
We want the right machine to be usable
You could have the greatest you could have a CT scan at home. You don't use it. It doesn't go any good. So
You have to have tools that you could utilize and that they could be a part of your life and that they could be a benefit to your health
We're talking about health tools like this. So I want to be as specific as possible
So I put a a before your name so it comes out alphabetically first. So it'll be the first folder when you open your home screen
On your right that's going to be the folder that's going to be your first folder that you see
One information here, but it's it's some when you go to
Store to purchase the right you'll see where you could fill out that form the word probation
You can give us on that educational intake form. The better it will be now sometimes people need it reprogram
Sometimes they need something changed like oh, no my my daughters headaches are great using the same example
But she's having some you know issues with x y and z can you program that we're here to do that
There's a cost of that for that and right now
I think it's $135 it might go up or down as time goes on
But we're here to reprogram that and tweak your program, you know as you want that tweak because again
I want you to be able to use this so we're here for customer service. We're here to pray for you, too
so when we have our
Prayer box for you to submit prayers we mean that so we will be here to pray for you in anything you need as well
We have other services available that you can add on through our courses certainly look at those as well
They will give you a plethora of information that will help you in different ways as well
And know that will be praying for you through your health journey through your life God has a plan in this as he does in all things
Thanks so much. Bye bye